hello everyone sorry about no video
yesterday I was really busy but here we
have a very nice game that's played
between Daniel Negreanu and a person
named Juan Carlos barber I have no idea
if this is indeed his name but he does
have a photo on his profile so as well
it might as well be so I'm not gonna be
using the hoodie as I don't think this
qualifies as the hoodie guy now a lot of
you have been asking me you know do a
video on openings on this opening on
that opening and since I never really do
any videos on openings I thought I might
use this one as a video on openings it's
about the Danish gambit and it's it's
interesting because it comes as a
suggestion from mr. Vincent van Dara as
you can see he tagged me so conveniently
on Twitter but also from Danny on the
ground of himself as he's asking how did
he do with the Danish gambit here as he
didn't really he wasn't able to share it
properly so he he took a photo most
likely with his smartphone and then
shared it publicly so I thought it'd be
a very nice opportunity for us to you
know check it out and let's see how he
did now Daniel is no professional chess
player but he is indeed a professional
poker player he won the World Series of
Poker bracelet six times which is the
highest award any poker player can
achieve that okay aside from money and
he he hopes to world what's it called
World Poker Tour Championship titles and
he's in 2014 I read he was proclaimed as
the best poker player of the decade
there is something called the global
poker index which kind of ranks players
perhaps similarly in a way that chess
players are ranked by elo so it doesn't
really strike me as a surprise because
most of my friends and acquaintances
that play chess also enjoy Texas Hold'em
poker really much I enjoyed myself so
it's not really a surprise that Daniel
would play poker and I've seen a lot
that he plays it a lot of on Twitter he
promotes it now and then and he this is
the first time perhaps he did it before
but this is the first
actually seen him share games I will
also put a link to his profile in the
description below so feel free to
challenging so let us start with this
game and see if we can analyze it so the
game as we've already mentioned is the
Danish gambit would have efore IE 5 d 4e
captures on d4 it's the central game and
des now comes C 3 this is the Danish
gambit and mr. Huang calls Barbour
accepts it we have D captures on c3 it's
a it's an opening that dates
pretty much to 1867
it was first popularized by Martin 7
from I in a tournament but it so it's
not really used in serious tournaments
nowadays as it black if black defends
properly our white can't really claim
any advantage but basically you want to
give up a lot of points early on and
then use your pieces to finish off your
opponent quickly and you know with with
great style it's ok but Bishop to c4
offering yet another pawn and unlike
unlike for example the Evans gambit
where you don't want to grab but the
third point is well here you can
actually do it and here it is indeed
perfectly normal so see capture some b2
and now we have Bishop captures and we
do so what did why a white gain for his
material he has two months two bishops
here and black has to be very careful
how he will proceed from here here the
game played the move played in the game
is not the greatest of moves here you
can choose between moves like for
example Bishop to b4 check let's see if
I have to be for check then white will
click into f1 you don't want to block as
you want to claim your advantage in
development not allowing black to trade
any pieces and after Knight of six now
e5 I want to force black to keep your
skin in the center for as long as
possible
now comes the five you attack White's
bishop on c4 year your year up in
material so everyone exchange as many
pieces as possible Bishop to b5 check
now butcher blocks and now comes Queen
to a for this comes with an attack on
the bishop here and also black's knight
on f6 is still under attack and here
black can go
Bishop back to e7 giving up the knight
on f6 he captures the bishop captures
Bishop capture Sun d7 Knight capture Sun
d7 and now Queen to a3 preventing black
from castling and also black does have
to figure out what to do
for example Bishop to e7 queen g3 you're
pressuring the g7 pawn and now Bishop to
f6 pressuring the this Bishop here so
black and a white hand hitter decides to
exchange here or repeat point to a3 and
go into a weird draw variation or for
example Bishop captures and now after a
queen captures nice the c3 and white
would indeed be up a piece but still
with the stroke still on h1 and this
knight and developed a black will be
able to you know play play this game
which is not what I would suggest if
someone plays this against you and you
allow this position to come up I my
favorite to move here is actually d5 and
it's it goes into a pretty forced
variation because now if you play the e
capture Sun d5 white blocks is on light
square Bishop and then you can simply
start developing Knight to f6 you can
play Bishop to d6 you will block this
pawn here and the black will have a much
better game so after d5 here white will
have to capture with the Bishop Bishop
captures on d5 and now after Knight to
f6 Bishop captures on f7 a black will
allow white to temporarily grab his
Queen after King captures Queen captures
and now if it's a bullet game or a blitz
game you will win a lot of free games
with this Bishop to b4 check move now
some if someone isn't careful they might
block with with the bishop with the
knight on D to which the knight and c3
and if that happens you can simply
capture the Queen and now you can see
that if you count only the minor pieces
that black has four minor pieces White
has three minor pieces so black is up a
piece here and completely winning so
when black delivers this Bishop to b4
check white will have to move the Queen
all the way to d2 block this check with
the Queen and force black to lose one
more piece in order to capture White
Queen so but four characters and Knight
captures and after rook to e8 black will
have an excellent
game and it requires much much less
calculations and it's a lot less
complicated than the previous variation
that starts with Bishop to b4 so okay
but in the game also just wanted to
mention this Bishop to b4 check and the
d5 this is my favorite you can also
learn I c6 but you know you're not
really a popular way in the game Bishop
to c5 was played and this is already a
losing move for black it's losing
because you can capture on g7 and of
course you're going to lose the rook
here but the Daniel doesn't go for this
perhaps he didn't want to go into couple
complications after Queen to h4 but it
is indeed still playable Queen to f3
guards against everything but okay
instead after this Bishop to c5 he goes
Queen to b3 attacking putting more
pressure on the f7 pawn here we have 90
to h6 defending although you could have
still gone Queen to h4 with which the
same ideas but okay we have Bishop
captures on g7 or even better than Queen
to h4 you could have gone knife to 36
and then after white captures King get
to f8 black will still have a very nice
game but okay after Queen to b3 we have
nice to h6 guarding the f7 pawn but
you're gonna lose the g7 pawn which is
also kind of important we have Bishop
captures now comes rook to g8 attacking
the bishop and now Bishop captures on h6
here rook captures and g2 was played but
here again black had a very nice move
Queen to f6 and again with the same idea
pressuring the f2 pawn the Queen is also
threatening to capture the bishop here
and the rook is can capture on g2
whenever it wants but okay rook captures
and g2 was played and here comes Bishop
captures on f7 now you can see that
black really doesn't have all that many
moves King to e7 is the only legal move
black can make we have King to e7 and
now comes Queen to d5 other than Queen
to d5 you can't really guard the f2 pawn
even though it's attacked twice if you
try something like three three then you
get better captures and now if you
capture with the Queen you're gonna lose
the bishop but it doesn't matter if pawn
captures your Queen to f8 will be enough
for black to equalize this game as
you're gonna lose the bishop now and of
course if you move the
it's not gonna be enough as queen is
coming to have to queen - f - checking
d1 and now rook can capture in g1
captures captures and here after black
develops his pieces he will have a
better game so Danielle goes Queen to d5
pressuring the bishop here and now we
have bushel captures on f2 with check
King to f1 and now comes c6 first and in
between move before deciding what to do
White has to figure out what to do with
the Queen Queen to b3 although then you
also had this possibility of Bishop to
g5 check which wins the Queen because
now after black captures wrote captures
Queen captures you have a very nice
attack here the King has the more so
best movement with which capturing a
piece and after King captures you will
capture the Queen on d8 black loses the
Queen and the game but okay after c6 f
Queen to b3 was played and still black
has to decide what to do here his rook
is under attack if he moves the roof his
Bishop is under attack so he plays rook
captures on g1 we have rook captures and
g1 Bishop captures and g1 and here
Daniel doesn't automatically recapture
but rather only now he plays Bishop to
g5 with check
we have kicked the d6 and now better
captures and e8 capturing the Queen and
now of course the black is completely
lost Bishop captures an h2 was played
and now Queen the d3 check King to c5
twins the c3 check and now of course if
you go to d6 Queen to d4 will be
checkmate
but after Queen to see if we check King
Tubby file was played here we have night
to a3 check although interestingly Queen
to a5 was checkmate in one but okay
first nice to a tree check we have King
to a6 and now comes Bishop to c4 check
again Daniel
most likely as this is a blitz game or
perhaps I think it's actually a 10
minute game but who knows perhaps he
missed that the bishop was also covering
the a5 square so again Queen to a5 would
have been checkmate but okay you know
it's important to win not win
immediately
Bishop to c4 check we have b5 blocking
and now Russia back to e2 we have
six and now hope to be one bringing
another piece into the attack although
Queen to a5 check would have again elite
the checkmate after King to b7 Queen to
c7 check King goes back and now Queen
captures son c8 will be checkmate as the
bishop is covering the dark squares here
a bar okay
we have d6 rook to be won and now comes
the bishop to HT to recheck black wants
to try to create some counter play
although it will be very hard as he
really has no compensation for the Queen
we have King to e1 and Mountain Knight
to d7 trying to develop his pieces well
you do have to allow Queen captures here
but okay Queen captures and now the
bishop can the knight can block nice to
be six we have Bishop captures pawn
captures and here we have Queen captures
on d5
although as there is no way for us to
know but perhaps Daniel was just
torturing the poor guy as he again does
not play mate in one which his Queen
captures on a eight but okay after a cat
person b6 queen capture some b5 with
King to be seven and now Queen to d5
with check King to b8 rook captures and
b6 this comes with check King to a7 and
now comes Queen to b7 and this is now
checkmate
so that was a very nice game of the day
near gambit and it served us a very nice
purpose of you know checking out a
couple of variations from this very
rarely played opening and to answer
Daniel's question how did he do which
the Danish gambit well after this after
the initial moves for example c3
captures Kappa head Bishop to c4 captors
and b2 bishop character Sam Bishop to c5
while Bishop captures on g7 was best
okay Queen b3 still white can play it
black missed a very nice opportunity
here to equalize 9 2 H 6 and after
Bishop captures on g7 it was pretty much
pretty much a good game rook to g8
Bishop captures rook captures and g2
although like we've said Queen to f6 was
better here but then after this Rock a
person g2 it was from move 8 that then
never lost advantage in this game so all
in all a nice showing of a lot of
dangerous poisons and you know
possibilities that are offered in the
Danish gambit so I do hope you enjoyed
that and I as this game I also felt that
we needed a nice break from all the
serious games and all of the intense
tournaments that have been going on so
far after this game we are returning to
our Bobby Fischer series which I am
definitely planning on ending before the
start of the World Chess Championship
match between mega Scott's and Fabiano
caruana perhaps all also cover some of
the games between Carson and Khurana
just to get in the mood some of them may
be from before that I haven't already
covered and before the start of the
World Chess Championship match I will
also check up on some of your
suggestions like this one here so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Kirk Siebert Elly
Martinez and Michael Hildebrand for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos you're
thankful for watching and hopefully I
will see you soon with some more
interesting content thank you all and
I'll see you soon